Hikaru Nakamura became champion of
Norway chess after overtaking the leader
Fabiano caruana in the final game in
round nine it was the streamer versus
the podcaster Hikaru started the game
with a variation he had not played in
years something that I have not played
in a very very long time over 14 plus
years on move 17 Fabi made a
game-defining mistake with Pawn to F5
Hikaru took a 22 minute think before
making the critical response Bobby's
next move took even longer the position
greatly favored Hikaru even his second
Chris Littlejohn was impressed very
promising for Yoko right now later in
the game Fabi moved that same
Troublesome Pawn to F4 another big
mistake from there Hikaru put on a
master class on converting the advantage
and achieving Victory after his
impressive performance Hikaru had this
to say for whatever reason I think I'm
playing Better In classical than I am
playing in Blitz or rapid in probably
the last six months the future is bright
especially after